[Music]
foreign
yeah the matching onesies can only mean
one thing Kiki Palmer's over the moon
about life with a newborn oh my gosh yes
the new mom hopped on Twitter to share a
peek of Life at home almost two weeks
after welcoming her first child with
boyfriend Darius Jackson a son named
leotus and it appears Kiki's taking
advantage of nap time come on let's talk
about it the couple snap selfies from
the couch as mom and son have a twinning
moment Darius planting a kiss on his
love but he can't go too far leotis is
fast asleep on Dad's chest
[Music]
this comes after Kiki's adorable
Serenade
[Music]
singing along to Mariah Carey's it's a
wrap
[Music]
but really even just two weeks into
Parenthood baby leonis has been exposed
to all kinds of tunes
[Music]
Mom and Dad treating lyodus to some 80s
R B love
foreign
and the part is the role of a lifetime
mom people have been in my comments
saying Kiki's having a baby Kiki's
pregnant and I want to set the record
straight I am
yeah that was life before the Otis when
Kiki did her baby bump reveal on
Saturday Night Live this has been the
blessing and I am so excited guys I'm
gonna be a mom
of course those in Kiki's Inner Circle
like Lonnie love learned the good news
ahead of time you know
I just love the way that she did it and
we're just so happy for her and she's
happy and healthy and that's what
matters congratulations Kiki just came
on here to say
if you are a single parent
pull out your cape and now they're
Kiki's deep in newborn life she's got a
new appreciation for all the parents out
there because I know there's a million
and one reasons why somebody wants to be
a single parent but when it comes to
raising a kid I've already learned in
these short few days that
it takes a village Kiki doubles down on
that in the caption quote I ain't gonna
lie I'm getting cooked and I just want
anybody out there that is a single
parent that's been doing this
um friends of mine people that I don't
know family members of mine
I'm really in my in my heart
bring tears to my eyes I am just truly
profoundly impressed
you have my respect sister
[Music]